miguel anotó 144 puntos esta temporada
de fútbol anotó todos sus puntos con
goles de campo de 50 yardas de hecho eso
es bastante impresionante porque bueno
50 es casi como romper récord entonces
parece que miguel es un individuo
bastante bueno en el juego muy
impresionante este chico así que anotó
todos sus puntos con goles de campo de
50 yardas voy a subrayar esto porque eso
es impresionante de miguel y los cuales
valen valen cada uno tres puntos ajá así
que un gol de campo en fútbol americano
de hecho es voy a dejarse un claro
porque no estamos hablando de fútbol en
el que pateas la pelota sino fútbol
americano un gol de campo vale tres
puntos cada uno él jugó 16 juegos esta
temporada cuántos goles de campo anotó
miguel en cada juego asumiendo que es la
misma cantidad en cada juego así que
miguel es un chico bastante
impresionante y vaya que es muy
consistente porque anota goles de campo
de 50 yardas y la misma cantidad en cada
juego así que bueno vamos a pensar en
cuántos goles de campo anotó miguel en
cada
hay varias maneras de pensar en esto por
ejemplo podemos pensar cuántos goles de
campo anotó en la temporada así que
anotó 144 puntos 144 puntos y si
dividimos esto entre 3 porque cada gol
de campo te da tres puntos entonces el
número total de puntos dividido entre
los puntos por cada gol esto nos va a
dar el número total de goles de campo
que es lo que queremos entonces tenemos
aquí 144 dividido entre 3 lo voy a
escribir acá entonces 144 dividido entre
33 caben 14 4 veces 4 por 3 es igual a
12 restamos nos queda 2 y bajamos este
43 caben 24 8 veces exactamente 8 por 3
es igual a 24 y no tenemos residuo así
que 144 dividido entre 3 eso es igual a
48 entonces toda la temporada ha anotado
48 goles de campo goles de campo
ahora no hemos respondido a la pregunta
cierto porque se nos pregunta cuántos
anotó en cada juego y estamos asumiendo
que es la misma cantidad en cada juego
este es el total de goles de campo en 16
juegos y para encontrar el número o el
promedio que lass en cada juego vamos a
dividir esto entre 16 tenemos en total
48 goles de campo dividido entre 16
juegos esto es igual
48 dividido entre 16 es igual a tres
goles de campo por cada juego goles de
campo por cada juego y ya terminamos
entonces la pregunta era cuántos goles
de campo anotó miguel en cada juego y la
respuesta es tres goles de campo 3